you probably can't reach the head just  put me where up  I am trying not to look at your plush  oh man  damn it was nasty as hell in there bum  oh yeah why are you a plush toy  my 512 character alphanumeric  designation has no meaning but I have  shortened it to flak for the sake  remember  security criminal trying to break in  please pull him apart slowly  get angry  your natural bachelor but I know it's  sad let's go Freitas  all right  where did that come from  a lot of free time since you crashed us  here valence to give us a little chat  have unique lighting which is just for  me  there's quite a romantics I get it I'm  no good at dirty talk shut up you want  to hear some it's really beautiful  I am trying not to look at your blush  card beats  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  I'm at the bridge Bay Lex you here yes  you're designed to solve problems Felix  that's my job my chauffeur  you